this is the kind of lecture every
scientist would love to give a lecture
that acknowledges all the unknowns that
are out there ahead that you're going to
solve you weren't born with this
questions one way or another it's a it's
something that hits you that you walk
into the problem I've worked on for 40
years actually was a little bit of an
accident my luck has come from seeing an
opportunity it was just reaching for a
tough problem but something with a lot
of mystery that's all the students I
think they are learning from dr. Young's
experience how he became interested in
this particular scientific problem if
you're convinced that the problem is a
big one then you just buckle down and
keep with it I'm deeply inspired by him
because he encouraged me to keep on my
study you're now working at the edges of
what's known it becomes much more
exciting than just learning things that
are already known that's the essence of
scientific research if you're not
interested you can't do anything well I
think a key point is to focus on my own
really focus on my own way and everyone
be fine when you're excited every day to
get up you're moving in the correct
directions and the true as a scientist
you